- Celui-là, on l'a eu
en Normandie, aussi.
- Le poids des années
comme le poids des médailles
n'ont pas altéré sa mémoire,
ni son sens de l'humour.
- Ça, c'est des boutons.
(rires)
- Enfant du Nouveau-Brunswick,
Edgar Doiron s'est enrôlé
comme volontaire avec
le régiment North Shore.
EDGAR DOIRON, vétéran,Seconde Ge
- Je pense qu'il y avait
des gros vents, des tempêtes
de vent, puis on pouvait pas...
on était toutjours retardés.
C'était pas la date prévue,
le 6 de juin 1944; c'était
plutôt le 29 de mai.
- Ses souvenirs de guerre sont
lointains, mais bien vivants.
Du débarquement en Normandie,
où il a été blessé en juin 1944,
à son retour au combat pour
la libération des Pays-Bas.
MONIQUE DOIRON,
fille d'Edgar Doiron
- Il a eu 3 blessures de guerre,
puis il aurait pu revenir,
mais il a choisi de continuer.
Il parle beaucoup, beaucoup,
beaucoup de... de la guerre,
de l'horreur des enfants,
comme il nous a dit,
qui mangeaient des bulles de
tulipe, qui mouraient de faim.
Ça l'a beaucoup marqué, ça.
JEAN-PIERRE DOIRON,
fils d'Edgar Doiron
- Mais quand j'étais petit,
là, il en parlait pas. Il était
plus... réservé là-dessus.
- Ah! J'ai sauvé des...
- Au fil des commémorations
et des retours en Europe,
Edgar Doiron semble avoir
fait la paix avec la guerre.
- Je suis content d'avoir
fait ce que j'ai fait.
C'était important de
sauver du monde aussi
qui était en santé.
(cornemuse)
- Les employés de
la résidence Le Dufferin
tenaient à souligner de façon
spéciale ce 100e anniversaire.
(cornemuse)
Amélie Lépine a déjà
accompagné son grand-père
vétéran en Normandie et,
comme enseignante, elle a
souvent invité Edgar Doiron
à rencontrer ses élèves.
Pour elle, c'est plus
qu'un devoir de mémoire;
c'est corriger l'histoire telle
qu'on l'enseigne aux jeunes,
en parlant surtout
de la conscription.
AMÉLIE LÉPINE, enseignante
et petite-fille de vétéran
- Et on parle pas encore
des Canadiens français
qui sont allés à la guerre.
Puis là, il n'y en aura bientôt
plus. Puis moi, j'ai peur que
ces hommes-là, ce qu'ils ont
fait, ça tombe dans l'oubli.
- Il reste moins de
200 Canadiens encore vivants
parmi les 14 000 qui ont fait
le débarquement en Normandie.
- Je pensais jamais me rendre
à 100 ans. Mais ça passe assez
vite... si tu es pas malade.
- C'est tout un honneur.
Moi, je suis vétéran, je suis
retraité. Mon garçon, il est
infanterie, lui, et cornemuseur.
- Oui, Monsieur.
- Oui...
ULRIK JETTÉ, membre
d'infanterie et musicien
- C'est vraiment cool de voir
où est-ce que ce monsieur-là
s'est rendu et surtout savoir
un peu d'où il vient. Mais c'est
surtout le fait d'apprécier
qu'on a des libertés que,
malheureusement, ces jeunes-là
n'avaient pas à cet âge-là.
(cornemuse)
- À 22 ans, Ulrick Jetté
a exactement le même âge
qu'Edgar Doiron avait
lorsqu'il est débarqué
en France en juin 1944.
- Un héros, non, non...
Je me vois comme un soldat
qui a fait son travail.
- Ici Anne-Louise Despatie,
Radio-Canada,
Salaberry-de-Valleyfield.